(upbeat music)
- Welcome to "Ear Biscuits", the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk
about life for a long time.
I'm Link.
- And I'm Rhett.
This week at the round
table of dim lighting
we're gonna be catching
up with each other-
- Hey.
- About our spring breaks.
We did spring break, man.
- You're still Rhett?
- You're still Link?
- Yeah, I still am, man.
Yeah, our breaks kind of,
you know, they weren't,
this was the first year, I think,
that they weren't at the same time.
- [Rhett] Yeah.
- Because our kids go to
different schools systems
even though, what is school?
You know, with all of
this trying to come out
of the COVID of it all.
I don't wanna but-
- Yeah.
Spring break doesn't mean what
spring break used to mean.
- 'Cause school, nothing
means what it used to mean.
- But it does mean they don't have
to be on Zoom calls all day.
- Well it means that, yeah, there is-
- That's the only difference.
- Spring break still means there
is no school for that week.
It's just that our kids,
there's two different weeks.
So like mine was three weeks back now
and yours was last week.
So it's basically just
like, mine's not as fresh.
But I'll tell you a big thing did happen,
in terms of an update, and
it's kind of tied to the season
of spring break and that is
huge milestone in the Neal home.
- Fourth child.
Christy is pregnant.
- No, God, no.
- Listen, let's see how long
we can let that sit out there.
- Oh, I already said, "No."
I'm sorry.
- You mean, "Oh no, I don't, we don't know
if we're going to give
it up for adoption."
- No, it's not true.
- Okay. No.
- Quite the opposite.
In the Neal home we gained an adult.
Our oldest child, Lily,
freaking turned 18 years old.
- So now the adults
outnumber the children.
- Even as I'm saying
it I don't believe it.
Well in my house, I'm
not considered an adult.
- Well right, okay, that's true.
- And that is the running joke.
So now there are...
Christy has another adult in the house.
- There's two moms and three boys.
- So I wanna, I wanna talk
about that 'cause I need
to process that.
But let's start with your
vacation since it's very fresh.
I don't know if there's, you
know, if there's something
to kick it off here and
then we'll certainly
get back to you.
- I saw something.
- The adult in my home.
You saw something?
- I saw something
on my spring break.
Now we went to the beach
and we stayed in a,
like a community of condos
kind of on the beach.
Right?
And what I noticed pretty
early about this community
of condos is that while
there were other people
doing what I was doing
which is like, you know,
renting it for a week.
- [Link] Mm-hmm.
- There was a lot of people
who had chosen to retire
to this community.
- Mm-hmm.
- Side note, I was
like, "That seems nice."
You know, I'm like, I'm sitting there,
washing off my surfboards on
the like the little porch area.
- Uh-huh.
- And this British woman
in a robe with a newspaper
in one hand and a cup of
coffee in the other hand-
- That's the life, isn't it?
- She just walks out
and she says, "Hello."
And I'm just like, "Mary Poppins is here?"
- Oh gosh.
- And she was just-
- Mary Poppins?
Did she have an umbrella?
- Well if she had a third hand she would.
You don't need an umbrella
in Southern California, man.
- Well when I went to the
beach a couple of weeks ago
it was, it did rain the first two days.
- Well you picked the wrong week.
We had no rain.
It was beautiful the whole time.
- Yeah.
- [Rhett] And she was-
- No Mary Poppins on my trip.
- She, I was, you know, I
was cleaning my surfboard
and she was like, "Oh, I
thought they might be cleaning."
Like there's people who
come and clean or whatever.
And I was like, "Nope, just
me washing my surfboard."
And she was like, "I'm Margaret."
- She kept it going, huh?
- And I was like, "Hello, Margaret."
And she just seemed...
And later I saw her like
walking with her husband
and they just seemed
so happy and contented.
- That's 'cause you don't know 'em well.
- Well, I mean I don't know-
- I mean, they're human, it's-
- If I can be that old with a robe-
- It's hard to be happy
and contended, man.
Especially...
I'm actually concerned for her.
It's like, she lives in
this condo permanently
but then she's got these
people who just come in and out
of the place every week.
- I think she likes strangers though.
- I wouldn't like that part of it.
- But she does, you can tell.
That's why she-
- Did you tell her your name?
Did you get into a convo?
- I did.
She was like, "I'm Margaret."
I'm like, "Oh, I'm just Rhett, Margaret."
Actually, I didn't say that.
I should, now that I think about
it I should have said that.
"Would you like a cigarette?"
She looked like she
might've been a smoker.
But-
- What do you mean by that?
- Nothing.
And then-
- Are her lips...
They...
- She just looked-
- Sometimes I feel like-
- I'm not an advocate of smoking.
- I can look at the lips of
people who I think are smokers
and 'cause growing up I
do know there is a certain
wrinkly lip associated with
the pouting of the lips
for smoking cigarettes.
- Well I wasn't talking
about a sad smoker.
I was talking about a cool smoker.
There's a difference.
- Well that shouldn't
be talked about at all.
- I know-
- We shouldn't do anything
to coolify smoking.
- It's not the Marlboro Man.
We've been through that generation.
I'm not trying to bring it back.
I'm just saying I believe
that Margaret might've been
a part of the Marlboro Man generation.
Like a cool, cool smoker.
Anyway, she just had that vibe
and her voice was a little raspy.
But that's not even what
I wanted to talk about
because I saw another woman,
speaking of contented, good Lord.
I'm walking with the
boys, so there's like one,
it's one of those, you know, up and down
the Southern California
coast for a large portion
of the California coast
there are these bluffs.
- Yes.
- You know what I'm saying?
It's not like North Carolina
where it's just like
you kind of go over some sand
dunes and there's just beach.
In California you got bluffs.
So basically these dirt cliffs.
And so the beach accesses
are kind of few and far between, right?
And so there's, for this
whole community there's one
and it's a giant thing.
So we're walking through
the entire community
with our surfboards getting
ready to go down the steps
and the way that this thing is organized
is it kind of, it's a
tree of roads that go out
into multiple cul-de-sacs, right?
- Okay.
- So we're having to like walk through one
of the cul-de-sacs to
like get on this path
and there's a woman, she's
also old, and she is walking.
I was like, "Oh, a retiree
out for a morning walk."
But we're walking down
the road, so I can see her
at the end of the cul-de-sac and I'm like,
"Oh, this woman has just reached
the end of the cul-de-sac
and she's looping around."
But then I notice she loops
in the cul-de-sac again.
And then I notice she loops
She's looping in the
cul-de-sac, that's her walk.
- She's stuck in the cul-de-sac.
- I don't know if she was stuck in a loop
or if this was intentional.
I believe it was intentional.
And I'm like, "This is
an interesting choice
because it's not like
leaving the cul-de-sac
presents new challenges."
You know what I'm saying?
It's like, it's still a flat road.
- It sounds like the
senior citizen version
of a dog chasing its own tail.
- But she seemed happy.
But it's like-
- Like a dog chasing its own tail.
- But that's only one aspect of this woman
that I wanted to relay.
The second aspect is the
fact that she is listening
to a book on tape is what I still call it.
- She got a Walkman?
- And how did I know what
she was listening to?
Because she was holding her
phone and it was on speaker.
- Ah, I've seen this before.
Yeah.
As you're approaching
you're realizing this
and you're also realizing I'm
not only gonna meet her once,
I'm gonna have to meet her twice.
- Well-
- On both sides of the cul-de-sac.
- No, the timing is
such that I could either
completely bypass her-
- Oh.
- Or I could cross her once.
But I'm not gonna get stuck in that loop.
- This is a strange practice.
- I mean, I thought about
getting stuck in the loop
just out of sympathy,
just once, just like,
"Come on boys, we're gonna
take a loop with this woman
and then we're gonna release
and go to the beach."
- But she's listening to
a book on speakerphone.
- Not just any book-
- Why?
- She's listening to a romance novel.
- What?
- Because the only thing
that I made out was,
"She grabbed him by the hips."
- Yes.
- So she was listening to
a romance novel, on a loop,
on speaker and I happened
to get the sex scene.
Which I mean they're pretty
frequent in a romance novel,
probably three or four,
every three or four loops
she probably has a sex scene.
It's a pretty big cul-de-sac.
- Well, it has, I would say
every three or four chapters
is a sex scene.
- Well it depends on who the author is.
But I was like, "This woman
is living her best life."
- So did you get behind her
when you started to hear the hips?
- No, I thought that
would be inappropriate.
But it hit me, I was
like, "There are things
about this scenario-"
- It's so weird.
- "That I could, I could
worry about this woman."
Like if this woman was my
mother or my grandmother
I'd be like, "Yeah, grandma,
she's stuck in a loop again
and she's listening to a
romance novel on speaker."
But then it, I saw it in a
different light and I was like,
"This woman has made the
choices that she wants to make
without regard to anyone's opinion."
I mean, I don't, she's not
stupid, she didn't look stupid.
And she didn't care.
She didn't care that I knew
that she was in a loop.
She didn't care that I
knew that she was listening
to a romance novel that the
sex scenes were penetrating-
- Okay.
- The air and my ears
and my children's ears.
I admire this woman.
I'm not concerned about her at all.
I just wanted to relay
it as a beautiful picture of humanity.
- I just don't, I...
Is there a reason why she's
listening on speakerphone?
Is it-
- That's the thing
you're taking issue with?
- Yeah, that is the one thing.
- You're just bypassing the loop?
That makes sense to you?
- Yeah, it's like, maybe,
you know, I could come up,
I don't really care about that.
You're right.
But the, but the it's just
like the people who talk
on speakerphone like
this, I think it's tapping
into a pet peeve of mine.
People in public talking on a
speakerphone when they should,
and they'll listen and
then they'll put the phone
up to their mouth as if
it's not on speaker phone
in order to talk into it.
- Oh, people do this a lot.
- Like I don't...
Like this is a version of
that that's even worse.
- I think it might be a distaste for-
- Headphones.
- Like not knowing how to use headphones
or keep up with them.
Or maybe she just lost 'em.
- Well I don't have my headphones
but I still got to get my story.
- Yeah.
- I think the explanation of the loop-
- She definitely calls it my story.
- Is simpler than we might think.
I think it could be, again,
nothing against people
who are aged but it
could be a bladder issue.
It could be like, "I
don't, if I need to pee
I don't want to be too far
away from my apartment."
Right?
"I don't want to be on the
other side of this complex
when it hits me."
- Maybe she just got back
home but she wants to hear
more of her story so it kind
of like, with a podcast,
you might sit in your
driveway to finish it up
before you go in the house.
But again, that's, this
is why I, the other part
is the part I care about.
Yeah, maybe there's-
- I don't really care about her reasons.
This is ultimately what I'm saying.
- I know that's your
point, that you don't care
about the reasons.
But that one, the using
a speakerphone on a phone
in general bothers me.
Except in very narrow situations.
- Hmm.
- When you're like you
want your whole family
in the living room to
hear what grandma's saying
on the phone call, you know.
- Sometimes I don't want to
hold the phone to my ear though.
- I don't like doing
that either, but I'll,
I will go through the
trouble to put in the...
- What if you don't have your headphones?
- The headphones.
- There are some times when I'm-
- I put it to my ear, man.
- I'm doing something-
- I use it like a phone.
- Well, no, there's sometimes
when like, never, never
in public, but if I'm in the
house and Jessie calls me
and she's talking to me,
and Jessie does this too
I've noticed, I haven't really
thought about this until now.
Like my wife talks to her
sister quite a bit, right?
And there are many mornings
where I go into the bathroom
and Jessie is like getting
ready in the bathroom
and she's just got her
phone on the counter
and she's having a
conversation with her sister.
Like that's very common.
And I feel like I get that.
You want it to be in your ear?
I mean, I'm just saying at your house.
- If you're getting ready
and you can't put stuff
in your ears and, 'cause
your face is getting wet
or something-
- Sometimes you just don't
want to hold it up here though.
- When you're doing stuff
with both your hands.
Yeah.
But ideally there'd be a...
I mean, I do that.
I put the ear earbuds in.
But I, yeah, you're right.
I'm sure there's a way
to just celebrate it
and say, "You know what,
she's doing her thing.
Let's stay out of it."
- Yeah.
The woman in the loop.
- But you're right about the
cliffs, to get back to that.
I mean 'cause we went to, a
little further south than you,
our vacation was Del Mar.
So we're like at like
Torrey Pines nature reserve.
You've got, there's
Torrey Pines Golf Course
on the south end-
- Very famous.
- But then there's like this,
this big point that comes out
and it's this reserve where
these Torrey Pines reside.
I think it's one of the
only places on earth
where these particular pine trees grow.
- What makes them so Torrey?
What does that even mean?
- I looked at 'em and they,
I rode my bike up there
and they didn't look that,
I couldn't have said,
"Wow, I've never seen a
pine tree like this before."
It was a little bit
different but it wasn't like-
- I mean are they-
- You'd have to be a (indistinct) I think.
- The limbs start at the top-
- [Link] No.
- At the bottom, are they all
across straight at the top?
- Erm, yeah, it's not tall and slender.
It's more wide and even from the-
- Like a giant Christmas tree?
- But not rectangular either.
It's more-
- Rectangular?
You mean triangular?
- That's what I meant, yeah.
- Oh.
- Triangular.
- The old rectangle
tree, and so I was like,
"Well I am interested in this."
- It is a little bit more like unshapely,
going in all types of directions
than it being vertical
and triangular in nature.
But you can also, you
have to time your hike
down on the beach in front
of Torrey Pines Reserve
for the tides.
I mean a lot of the beach
here it just goes away.
You get so excited about
renting a place at the beach
and then you get there and you realize
first of all I'm like
45 feet above the beach
and I can't just walk
out and just go down.
Like, that's the North Carolina beaches
that have spoiled us where it's just like
100 yards of beach-
- Right.
- Before you get to the water.
And you have to time it right to hike
that, the frontage part,
like the beach part
of Torrey Pines Reserve.
And one of the main
things you got to watch
out for is you can't walk
too close to the cliffs
because I mean, and I read
this thing in their brochure-
- They'll fall.
- Like a dude died.
Like boulders fell down like
a little, a little landslide
and just killed the guy.
- And it happens not infrequently.
- Yeah.
I mean, last time we went to the beach,
closer to where you were, we
set up our stuff on the beach
and the lifeguard came over and
said, "You need to get away.
You're too close to the cliff.
You've gotta be closer to the
water because it's dangerous."
- And I was told by somebody
who lives down there,
so there's all these really nice homes
that are like right at the
top of the bluffs, right?
And you see that some
of them have like a deck
or something or a patio that
literally it's beginning
to erode underneath their patio.
- Yeah, like there.
- And I don't know, I'm
maybe speaking out of school,
I'm just relying on
testimony of one individual
who lives down there but I
was told that if your property
falls into the ocean, or
falls off of the bluff,
you cannot rebuild.
So it's very difficult to get insurance.
So if your house...
And every few years
apparently somewhere along
California coast it's just like, "Oh-"
- "There goes my deck."
- Somebody lost their house
or a portion of their house
it become, it gets condemned
and there's nothing you can do.
I was also told that the steps
that come down from the homes
to the beach, which a
few homes have those,
if those go away, you can't rebuild those.
- Hmm.
You know the steps up at Point
Dume, just north of Malibu
there's that huge point-
- Where our very first ever
paddle boarding excursion,
which was a part
of the Mythical show.
- We had to walk down all
of these flights of stairs
with those paddle boards
in order to get down there
'cause it was more of an
isolated beach on the south side
of Westward Beach.
And that's where we tried to learn
because it was so isolated.
And I took Christy there
for Valentine's day,
we we're gonna have like a,
well we were just gonna have
a beach date.
- Don't tell me the steps are gone.
- And it was so windy I
was like, "I know the place
where we need to go."
And we went to that place
and yeah they have removed
all of the steps.
I don't think they
eroded away or anything.
They removed all of it.
- You can't get to Point,
you can't get down there to the beach?
- And then there's like
tape up, like caution tape,
and there's a crane.
I think they're gonna rebuild it all
because there's a crane there,
and it's been there for a year though.
And-
- That's like a beautiful spot.
- I was like, "We're here,
this is a beautiful spot,
it's Valentine's day, there's
no, there's so much wind,
this is the only place that
isn't gonna have wind."
And I go underneath the caution tape
and I'm like, "We're just
gonna go down the steps."
And then once we go under
there with our stuff I'm like,
Christy's behind me, I'm like,
"There are no steps anymore
but there are people down on the beach
so if they can do it, we can do it."
So then for the next 20
minutes we're like on our butts
with like-
- Sliding down the-
- With like a cooler
and a freaking blanket
and like you're just trying
to get down the cliff.
- You didn't end up having
sex on the beach, did you?
'Cause I know that you
guys like to do that.
- I, you know, how it is when you like,
you have these thoughts in your head
and then like when you're
actually living the reality of it.
- Oh, you were thinking about it?
- Well I'm always thinking about it.
- 'Cause I know you also bring
a blanket wherever you go
regardless of the season.
- It's key to bring two blankets
for such a scenario as this.
- A really big blanket will work.
- Yeah, one that'll fold over.
- Yeah.
- I mean, I've got, I've
got privacy standards.
Good gracious.
But yeah, none of that.
I mean, it was, basically it
was a near-death experience
to get down there and then the whole time
we're just kind of worried
how much, is it gonna be
more difficult to get back up?
- Yeah, I get so anxious
about that kind of thing.
Like, "Are we gonna..."
Like I'm always like, "You know what?
I know I can do it but
I don't know if the rest
of my family can do it."
You know what I'm saying?
And I feel responsible for them all.
- And when we were coming
down there was this
like really buff, huge guy
and this really small girl.
- Typical Malibu.
- And then they were in a fight
because he was down at the
bottom yelling at her half way
to just, "Come on down."
But not in a "Price is Right" kind of way.
In a like our relationship is-
- Hinging on this moment.
- Hinging on this moment kind of a way.
- As it should.
- She did, she did get down
there and then she did,
you know, she took off most of her clothes
and he started taking pictures of her.
- Oh, she's an Instagram model?
- Apparently.
That's what happened.
But-
- Did you ask her for her handle?
- Erm, no.
- "Hey, I'm really interested
in what you've got going on
here, I would really like to see
it on the internet."
- No, but, I mean Christy
talked to her and encouraged her
that she did a good job of
getting down the mountain.
- Oh, really?
I thought you were about-
- But I will say that Christy passed her
and just showed her how it's done.
Yeah, girl.
- We need to talk about, not right now,
but just file this away,
the Instagram handles
that are on the back of
trucks in North Carolina-
- Oh, Lord.
- Which is a whole phenomenon.
- I've heard about this.
- We got to get into that one day.
- Yeah.
Well I know we're going back
home and it's like maybe,
I think we'll have fresh eyes coming back
from going back home.
Hopefully we'll see some of that.
- You know what?
I'm saying right now when
I go back home this summer
I'm gonna be on a mission to
catalog all the Insta trucks
that I see and then I'm
gonna have an Insta truck off
on my Instagram.
- Oh, shoot.
Well, hold on, I wanna join in on this.
- Okay. Well it can be a tournament.
Who can, who, okay.
You get your...
Who gets the best...
Who gets the best Insta truck?
It goes by who finds the
one with the most followers
wins a truck.
- Okay.
All right.
So one of us is gonna buy
the other guy a truck.
- But it could be any truck.
It could be like a $200 truck
that somebody's trying to get rid of.
- Okay, this is fun.
This is fun.
All right.
Challenge accepted.
Let's sell some merch.
Go to mythical.com and pick
up this, what does it say?
- [Rhett] It says, "Mythical is happi..."
- Ness.
- Happiness.
- "Mythical is happiness."
And the fact that it takes
that much work to read it-
- Is what makes it cool.
- Is part of the beauty of it.
I love how this thing fits.
It's like a stonewash.
It's thinner so as it gets
warmer you still want to have
that nice hoodie.
Like you wanna...
It's got a nice spacious hood to it
and it's not-
- Mm, spacious hood.
- I don't like a hoodie that's too thick.
I mean, at this time of year.
This is perfect for right now.
Go to mythical.com.
Also check out our Amazon
store 'cause we've got stuff
that's only there, amazon.com/mythical.
- I'm switching out my mug.
- Switching out your mug?
- Putting some water in it.
All right.
- So two weeks, I mean,
I think it was, yeah.
Episode before last in the video version
we were, we cut to
footage of Jessie filming
each of our kids when we
first moved to Los Angeles,
when they were in the airport-
- 10 years ago.
- We were talking about
the 10 year anniversary.
And you know, I know a
lot of you got a kick out
of seeing that video.
I mean, I'm just, my heart
just melts at how little
our kids were.
And we've already talked
about this except to say
that like Lily was seven.
She is, she's, and she
was, okay, she was about
to turn eight.
- Right, right, right.
- And now she just turned 18.
It's like, I'm still
trying to come to grips
with the fact that like my
daughter, our first child,
is an adult.
It's the first time in a long
time I've had this sensation
that I had when Christy and I got married
because we were the first
ones in our friend group
to get married.
- Mm-hmm.
- And I was like, "Wow."
I mean, I know a lot of
people do this and it's,
and I know that it's
normal to feel nervous
but like in your immediate
friend group to be the first one
doing something that's such a statement
was, it added a little trepidation to it.
I remember that feeling
because that's kind of what came back
when I'm like, "Man, I have
another adult in the house."
But then the flip side
of that is I've done it.
Like I am super proud
of Lily and who she is
and who she's still becoming.
There's a lot of work
that she still has to do
but it ain't my work anymore, right.
Officially.
You know, I'm just like-
- It hasn't been for some
time though actually.
- Yeah, practically speaking
that's absolutely true.
But it's, you know, there was
just this, there's a card,
there's like this trump card
that you can no longer play
when they're 18.
At least it feels like.
And it's like, okay, this
is really your decision.
I mean, when she turned 18
at the end of March I'm like,
"Hey, let's smoke some
cigarettes, join the military,
make the most of this."
- There's all this stuff that you can do.
- And she's like, "I
think I'll just, you know,
think about going to college
and make some progress there
and let's watch another
episode of 'Survivor.'"
You know, that's the, that's the thing.
I mean she's been accepted
at one of her top choices
but she hasn't made a final decision
because she's on a couple of waiting lists
for colleges for the fall.
But that's exciting.
We're gonna...
But you know, the COVID of
it all has changed so much
about this and it's-
- Yeah, the fact that this
is, that her senior year
was COVID is, it really
kind of sucks for her.
- Unfortunate.
- I think she has made the best
of it is how I see it, but...
- Well we really came
to appreciate how much
of an introvert she is.
- [Rhett] Yeah.
- That it's, I mean she's
not, she hasn't had a lot
of frustration and
suffering from just being
in her own space.
In a lot of ways she
actually thrived more.
So like her quality of life is good.
It has improved
in a lot of ways.
- Well it's interesting.
I was reading an article that
was about this very thing.
That was the people who have
secretly thrived during COVID
and almost there's a little
bit of shame about it
'cause they're like, "I know
that this has been horrible
but I've kind of been into this."
And I think it's an interesting contrast
like between Lily and Locke
because Locke is, you know,
extroverted but also just,
you know, super a challenger.
And so he, just like I said
in the video last week.
- [Link] Mm-hmm.
- And just the idea that like
he's constantly complained
about the fact that he feels
like that his junior year
was stolen from him, you know?
So I'm glad that it was his junior year
and not his senior year for his sake
just because the way that he is.
- Yeah.
And Lily doesn't.
Yeah, she doesn't talk like that.
So that's a good sign.
But it, you know, it's, I mean
going off to college is...
Especially with this
transition that she's making
from COVID and then kind of
getting back out into normalcy
and then being plunged into
this world of college adulthood
which I feel like is different
than non-college adulthood.
I mean, you know, that's
just my cents about it.
But it's, there's a lot
there in that transition.
And I think there has been this experience
of, and I'm this way, that
whenever I get stressed out
or intimidated by something
instead of diving into it
and figuring it out fully it's more like,
"Well if I can keep it at arms length
I won't have to be as worried about it."
I mean, it's nice that she's been accepted
at like one of her top schools
that she wanted to go to.
So like, okay, we know
that the plan's in place
and everything's going
but like the details
of like, right, we're
going to visit the campus
but we can't go in the buildings yet.
And so it's just kinda like
seeing the campus on our own,
there's no official.
They'll send you like a virtual tour
and stuff like that, but
it's, she hasn't really wanted
to like explore everything
about it because I think
it would make it feel even more real
and it's something that we
kind of want to ease into.
Because over the course of
COVID, I mean, she did not
really, she didn't have
a senior year experience.
So every, all of these
milestones that you would have
that would really gear
you up and prepare you
and excite you for this next
phase of life is just something
that didn't happen, you know.
And I'm not-
- Right.
- Yeah, you got graduation coming up,
which I don't, we still don't know
what that's gonna look like.
You've got the prom which
probably isn't gonna happen.
You've got all the other
things throughout the year
that seniors do that make you feel
like you're on the precipice
of the rest of your life
that, I mean, none of that happened.
For her birthday it just, it
takes a lot of work to be able
to commemorate anything.
You know, she's got her friends
driving by in the front,
hanging out in the
front yard at a distance
and, you know, she was
surprised by some of the people
that, you know, Christy
had contacted to show up.
So she was really honored
and it was really cool
but it's not, nothing is
tropish, nothing taps into,
"Oh yeah, this is how
people going into college...
This is how it works on the CW Network."
You know, like the
tropish dramatic version.
And so now you have this
identification with things
through just the typical practices.
So it's just been real strange.
- One thing for our
kids that I think helps
with this a little bit
though, compared to,
think about how predictable
our existence was
at that time in our lives, right?
We'd been going to school
with the same people
since first grade, you since kindergarten.
- Mm-hmm.
- And like, there was
just, I just think about
what COVID would have been like
at Harnett Central high school
in 1996, that senior year.
Like if all of a sudden
we couldn't go to...
First of all, like, how
would they even have done,
they couldn't have done online school
because no one had a computer at home.
Just like-
- Yeah.
- But you just think about
how we had these events.
One of the things that I've
noticed just about my kids
is that those tropish things
that you're talking about
like prom and this is how you do things
and you go to the football
game on a Friday night.
Like, I'm sure that's still happening
in a lot of places in America
but something about 2021,
and in Los Angeles
especially, their experience
is just kind of different.
- It is.
- So I feel like they
actually have more capacity,
I know this is contradictory
to what I was saying earlier
with Locke complaining about this stuff.
But I think, and also
the fact that they moved
in the middle of their
childhood to a new place
and they were homeschooled
and then they started
going to school.
And I just feel like our
kids are a lot more flexible.
- Her first public school
experience, we've gotta remember,
is going to high school as a freshmen-
- Right.
- With a student body of thousands,
literally thousands of students.
- I think the fact that she-
- She's made a hell
of a transition.
- Withstood that transition
all ready.
- Oh, yeah.
- Is like, I think it's, I
think that her transition
into college, my take
on it, is that it would,
it's gonna be less of a deal
for her than it would have been
for us if we had, if
everything had have been shaken
up so big.
- She's excited about it.
She can't, I mean, she can't wait for it.
She feels like, she
didn't, she had a strange
high school experience so it's, you know,
she's excited about starting college
on like more of an equal
footing with everybody else
which is in no way how her
high school career started.
And then it fizzled out
before it really got going.
And again, I'm just grateful
that she's been fine with it
and that she's found a way
to continue to be healthier
over the course of this past year.
So, you know, when we went
on our spring break trip
it was like, "Okay,
Lily, this is your last
spring break trip."
So we wanted to do what we could
within all of the
limitations that we have.
So she brought a friend,
which was great, great for her
and, you know, it's, you
know, it's a friend of like...
Her friend's family,
we're all friends, right?
So like we're all hanging out normally.
But, so it's like we know her really well
and so that was nice for
her to have a friend there
that like Lincoln was also
friends with and that.
But it brings a different
dynamic to a vacation
when you bring a, when
a kid brings a friend.
It makes, everybody's on
a little better behavior.
So I like that dynamic of it too.
- Oh, yeah.
- So she got a friend and we
all got to be a little more
cordial with each other
over the course of the week.
- And the kids behave more.
- Yeah.
'Cause they don't want to,
you know, you don't want
to throw, no one wants to throw a tantrum
and embarrass themselves.
- You don't want to show
your ass, so to speak
when there's non-family there.
- And I'm not talking about
Lando throwing a tantrum,
I'm kind of talking about me.
But, yeah.
I mean just, having an,
having an, and then just...
So whether it's spring
break or whatever it is,
just having this mentality
that like, and then I'll say
this a lot to the kids when
they're at each other's throats,
it's like, "You know, well,
Lily you're not gonna,
she's not gonna be here much longer,
she's gonna go off to
college and then, you know,
somebody is gonna have
to take care of her cat."
- You.
- The cat is gonna be how we
like feel a connection to Lily.
- Well that's interesting.
- By taking care.
That's why-
- The cat doesn't feel
that connection to you.
- That's how I'm trying to
work that out in my mind
is that like, okay I can,
me caring for the cat
when Lily is gone, until
we can get this cat to live
with Lily, which I assume
can't happen freshman year.
- You could probably sneak it in there.
- But now everything is kind
of shifted that way in terms
of like, this may be the,
this is, there's only a few
more months before Lily leaves
so we gotta make the most
of this, let's not, let's
not be jerks to each other,
kind of a thing.
- How's that working out?
- I can tell sometimes that it
actually works a little bit.
Like if I say something,
I mean especially Lando
because Lando, I mean,
you should read the card
that he like hand wrote a
letter to Lily for her birthday
and was talking about
how much he loved her
and how much he hopes that
her going off to college
will be a great experience and,
you know, it's super sweet.
But even Lincoln, you can kind of see.
It's like we all are like
coming to grips with the fact
it's like, we've never,
they've never lived life
without her in it so...
The wheels are turning for them
that like, okay, this is gonna be,
this is not gonna be easy.
This is gonna be sad.
And I mean I'm sure when we get,
I'll share the whole
experience when it comes
of like taking the daughter
to college and leaving her.
But like, man, it's hard
to, it's hard to think about
even right now because there's
so much emotion wrapped up
in this thing, you know,
of her leaving home.
But at this point it looks
like she's not going real far.
Like at one time she was like looking
at like the University of Hawaii
and she got accepted there
and we're like, "Oh, you don't...
I mean, Hawaii's great,
I'd love to have an excuse
to go there more often
but I don't like the idea
of you being stuck in the middle
of an ocean that far away."
So I don't think that's happening.
I think we're like far enough away
that like, this is my
prediction, she'll end up
far enough away that I
won't be able to see her
or her to come home every
weekend or every month
but if I need to get there,
I can, within a few hours.
- And she's not-
- Less than a day's drive.
- She's not the kind of person
who's going to be calling
you with every problem that she runs into.
Like, she doesn't strike
me as that kind of person.
- Yeah, I'm thinking of
ways to like, you know,
to foster more of a text connection.
To like build some habits
so that there will be,
like we'll be in the habit
of talking on a semi,
on a daily basis or at
least every couple of days.
So that's it.
Yeah, because I think
the tendency will be more
like you and I when we
went off to college.
It's like, well, first of
all I went home every weekend
to get my laundry done
and to see my girlfriend.
That ain't gonna happen with her.
So it's I, but besides that
it wasn't like I was talking
to my mom constantly or
processing my transition
with my mom.
- Right.
- I don't recall doing that.
- But, my goal is that-
- She called you.
Your mom called you.
- That would happen.
- But you didn't call your mom as much.
And it was kind of similar to me.
- Right.
- I mean in my mind I did,
I remember, and we were only
an hour away from home, going to college
and then seeing my mom
again on Thanksgiving.
Like that's, I know that's not true
but that's how I processed it.
And that's how like with
my kids, like if they,
like my kids go back to,
sometimes they'll like fly
to North Carolina, like
alone, to like spend time
with family and it'll be like a week
and neither me nor Jessie has communicated
with them in any form.
'Cause that's just their personal,
they're just, they're like me in that way.
And so I have a feeling that
there will not be the texting
every couple of days.
- But it is such a, going
to college is different
than visiting family, right?
- Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- So it's like, I think
you're gonna want to have more
of that connection-
- Especially initially.
- I'm trying to be strategic now and say,
"All right we gotta develop some habits."
Because if I just spring it
on her then I'll be badgering
her her first month on
campus and it would be like
not used to it kind of a thing.
I was thinking about that
this morning actually.
So, I mean, I think
that that was certainly
the defining experience
of my spring break.
I wanna hear more about
yours and I do think
that as we gear up
towards, and as she leaves
to go off to college
that I'll be processing
that so you'll be hearing about it.
But let's go to more of the temporal.
- Well...
- Vacation.
- I met another person on,
as part of this community.
- Okay.
- I actually met a lot of old folks
who were very curious about things.
Curious about the surf board.
Like I'm carrying the surf board
and I've got like my paddle
'cause I'm paddle boarding.
- Oh.
- And they're asking lots of questions.
And these people must've
not have lived there
because they would have known.
They were like, "What's the difference
between that and a regular surfboard?
Can I see it?
Can I see the bottom of it?"
- Oh, wow.
- Two couples just like asking questions.
It's good to be old and curious.
- Is your response like mine,
which would be I'm gonna
answer this while in motion so
as to say that I'm not gonna,
I'm not here to have a
conversation with you?
- No, I'm friendlier than you.
- So like, you'll like stop?
You'll like shift your
weight to your heels,
make eye contact with a stranger
and then have a meaningful conversation?
- As I did.
- That's vacation, man.
Good for you.
- But the more interesting thing-
- 'Cause my problem is I'd be like,
I gotta get in that water.
I'm on a mission.
- No, I was coming back from it.
I had already surfed.
- All right, I gotta get in the shower.
I'm on a mission.
- Oh, really?
- Yeah.
- Well, let me tell you,
I wonder how you would
have dealt with this.
So, we're getting ready to go
out and I had just purchased-
- Insurance.
- Two new boards for the boys-
- Life insurance.
- Like two foam boards because
we had like one and it...
Anyway.
And I learned something that
there's this soft top wax
for surf boards.
Like I always thought like,
"Oh, soft top surfboards
don't need any wax."
But the guy at the place was like,
"No, actually there's a
thing called soft top wax
and it'll make the
experience a lot better."
But it's a different wax, it's softer.
So we're like outside in the
little sort of common area
where it's like this
landscaping and grass and stuff
and we've got the boards out
there and I'm making the boys
like wax their boards.
- [Link] Mm.
- And this older dude
comes out of his condo
and he's got on a visor.
- Perfect.
- And I respect-
- Blocks the sun,
doesn't alter the hairdo.
- I respect the visor,
thought about wearing one
from time to time.
But he says, "Hey, (indistinct)."
And he just, you know how
when somebody begins talking
and you're like, "Oh,
this is one of those guys
who just likes to talk to people."
I can't even remember what the first thing
out of his mouth was but
it was almost just like,
"I've never met you
before but I'm picking up
where our last conversation
that we never had left off."
- It's like he's picking up
where the last conversation
left off with another stranger.
- With someone else.
Yeah. Right.
It's just, I'll just keep
going, I'll keep going
with these guys.
- And then I said.
- And so we were talking
to him for a little bit
and, you know, he's from, he
used to live in a similar area
in LA that we live in
and so he's like talking
about some like restaurants and stuff
and I'm like this guy, this guy
is he's a aggressive talker.
Now, as I said, I'm friendly,
I'm not an initiator.
- Mm-hmm.
- I don't initiate many
conversations with people
but I respond and engage in conversations.
- So you answered his questions
but you didn't ask questions.
- Oh, I didn't need to
ask this man any questions
to get any information.
But, so.
But he's kinda, you can tell
that he's sorta like sensing
okay, like, okay, here's a
dad and then there's a couple
of boys, teenagers, whatever,
and so he goes, you can tell
he's reaching into the
back pocket of his stories
that will impress teenage boys.
- Ah.
- He was like, "Well
when I was in college-"
- Oh.
- "I got a job with a beer
company delivering beer.
What kind of job is
that for a college guy?
Taking kegs around."
I'm like, "Oh, where's this going?"
The boys are getting a
kick out of it I can tell.
They love it.
They love hearing this kind of thing.
He's like, and then he
decides to like take it up
a couple of notches and he's like,
"And then this one
morning I got to deliver
to this strip club.
And I go in there in the
morning and it's the morning,
there's nobody in there but
there's a girl on the stage
shaking her titties."
- Oh, God.
- So, I mean I didn't say, at
that point I was just like,
"How long is this gonna go?"
Right?
'Cause it's like, he's gone from like-
- Well to me it's like,
what's gonna happen?
- I've said nothing, I've
not encouraged anything
and we've already got beer and titties
and where else do we go from here, right?
And so he keeps talking
and he finishes that story.
I mean, none of the stories were good
it just, they had buzzwords in them.
You know what I'm saying?
But they didn't have-
- Nothing happened.
- They didn't have a
beginning, middle and end.
- Okay.
- So he keeps going and at
this point we've, I can tell
that now Locke and Shepherd are kind of-
- If nobody's in the strip club-
- He's lying.
- Do they still dance?
It's kind of like-
- He's lying.
- If a stripper falls in
the club and no one's there,
do you hear it?
- Right.
Right.
He's lying because they
don't just go out there.
- But you don't know.
Neither one of us have
ever been to a strip club.
- Okay, I haven't been to a strip club
but I'm saying I know enough about life
and people to estimate
that if somebody comes in
they're like, "Oh, Shirley,
go out there on the stage."
But if no one's out there on the stage,
do you think Shirley's
just gonna be up there?
- But he was just delivering,
he was the delivery guy.
- Yeah.
- But maybe she could get some dollars.
- He didn't say he gave her anything.
But at this point in the story,
Locke and Shepherd have both
finished waxing and now they're
kind of waxing for show.
- Okay.
- You know, it's like, "Okay,
well I don't, I'm gonna keep
moving my hand but I've fully
waked my board at this point."
But he's just getting going.
- Oh.
- And so then he realizes-
- That's when I would have
not, I would have stopped,
I would have put the stuff
away and I would have stood.
- He then notices that I'm not
saying anything back to him.
I'm kind of fake laughing
at certain things.
- [Link] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- But then he's, I guess he
sensed that and he was like,
"So what do you do?"
- Oh.
- And I was like, "Oh gosh.
Oh gosh."
- Dad, beer, titties.
- This is such a loaded question
for us, as we've discussed
many times, and as you
have, you did at one point
when an Uber driver
asked you what you did,
you answered, "I make corporate videos."
Because you wanted-
- Yes, thank you for reminding me.
- You wanted to be truthful
but to shut the conversation down.
- No one wants to talk about
those corporate videos.
If the corporation happens
to be YouTube, so be it.
- And I, and so I-
- Google.
- I don't, I can't do that.
But I got pretty close.
I did what I usually do which is,
"I run a production company in LA."
That's what I, that's what I say.
It's probably a little too loaded.
- Yeah.
- Because he immediately responded with,
I know this is the anecdote
that he responds to anyone
that he finds out is even
tangentially involved
with the entertainment industry.
He says, "Do you know, they
made 'Titanic' in Tijuana?"
- What?
So, okay.
- And I'm like, "No."
He's like, "You didn't know that?"
Like he's disappointed in me.
Mr.
I-have-a-production-company-in-Los-Angeles
and I didn't know they made
the "Titanic" in Tijuana.
A movie that was made in the mid-'90s
that I have nothing to do with
because I'm not in the movie industry.
But so, and I'm like, "Really?"
- First of all he's,
you had to be relieved
that like it's immediately back on him
and you're learning something.
- I don't know if I'm
learning truth though.
I mean, it could be true.
- It doesn't matter.
Tijuana, Mexico.
- And so then he tells me the connection
that he has with a guy
who worked on the movie
and then he tells me a
story about them like,
"You know the scene where the water
is coming down the hallway?
Well first time they shot that
they didn't support the walls
well enough and it just
went in the hallway
and it just knocked the walls down."
And so he's proud of the
fact that he knows this
and he's strangely like a little bit irked
that I didn't know this.
I mean, how do you own a
production company in Los Angeles
and you don't know these classic
"Titanic" Tijuana stories?
- Quit now.
- But eventually when
I didn't really respond
much to that, because at this point
I was kind of losing my patience,
he was like, he didn't say
anything, he just turned
around and went inside.
- What?
- Yeah.
He was just like, and he was gone.
It was just like-
- What?
Hold on.
Okay. Hold on.
Did you see him turn and walk
away or was he just gone?
'Cause there might be an angel
situation happening here?
- No.
- A titty angel.
- I saw him go in.
I think he needed to get another beer.
I think this dude-
- Yeah.
- This dude's still about beer
and titties at this point.
And there's, I have to
believe there was a lot
of beer going on.
- I think that was the
name of a Ludacris album.
- Beer and titties?
- Yeah.
It isn't that but it's close to it.
- So-
- I can't believe he just walked away.
- Yeah.
I think that's his MO.
I think he's just like,
"All right, I'm done."
Drop the mic, go inside.
He doesn't, again, he
started the conversation
as if we were picking up
somewhere where we left off
with a conversation we
never had and he just ended
it with no pleasantries.
- Okay.
- Like no, "Have fun out there."
Or anything.
He was like, "Tijuana,
walls, titties, beer."
And he just turns around
and he's in his house.
- He knew you got what you came for.
- Right, yeah.
He's like, "I've been through it all.
I told the beer and titties story,
I've told the Tijuana story,
what else did these guys need?
What do they want from me?"
So we go inside-
- Did you tip him?
- And then Locke and Shepherd.
Locke and Shepherd-
- It feels like, "Should
I have tipped him?
I don't know."
- Locke and Shepherd are
like, "That guy was awesome."
Like they just thought he was great.
And I was like, "Well,
he's not really great
and he's not really awesome."
But let me tell you the
highlight, I've saved it for last.
- Oh, nice.
- I have a highlight of the vacation.
Not a lot happened, in a good way.
Right?
I mean it was kinda just
chilling in this condo.
- Yeah, that's what we did.
Lots of cereal eating,
some ice cream eating.
- Just taking it easy watching TV.
- Oh yeah.
- We did get deeply sucked
into another reality show
as a family.
Shout out to "60 Days In."
I know that some of you are fans.
- But, okay, you need to stay focused.
You've teased this big story.
- It's not that big.
I gotta tell you, I gotta
just give you the premise
of this show.
- I just don't, I know
how you are with this.
- No, no.
I'm not gonna talk.
- 30 minutes later.
- No, no, I'm not gonna talk about it.
I'm just gonna give you
the premise of the show.
The premise of the show
is that there is a sheriff
somewhere in the United
States, Arizona I think.
- Okay.
- And he has created this
program where he gets normal folk
to go to jail and it's technically jail,
it looks like a prison
situation, like more long-term,
but it's technically jail,
it's like holding people
for their court dates and stuff like that.
- Uh-huh.
- And he, you go in and you
become a prisoner, or an inmate,
or whatever the correct
word is, for 60 days.
And you, he, the Sheriff's
idea is that you're going in
as like a spy to like get
information so he can figure out
like how drugs are getting into the jail
and stuff like that and like all the-
- Is this a real jail?
- It's real and it's in its fifth season
and the fifth season is on Netflix.
And the first four seasons
I think we're on A&E.
It's mind blowing that this is a show.
- A real jail with real inmates.
- And they film the whole thing.
- But then you put in someone
who's guilty of nothing
in order to get information?
- You put like two or
three women with the women
and two or three men with
the men and you follow them
and you do interviews with
them and you do interviews
with other inmates and the
whole time it's being filmed.
And they think, everyone
in the prison thinks,
or in the jail, thinks that
this is just a documentary.
Because, you know, they film documentaries
inside these places all the time.
And I'm not gonna say that
it's quality television, but-
- So just because they're
incarcerated you can lie to 'em?
That seems suspect.
- There's a lot of
ethical questions raised
just by the fact that this show exists
but that didn't stop us from
consuming the entire season
in one week.
So anyway, it was, and the
kids were just, especially
Shepherd was just like really into it
and just kind of, we were
all kind of blown away
that it was, that this show happens.
And it kind of, that
effect never wore off.
Again, not quality television but just.
But the highlight of the trip
of course was interacting with the ocean.
Right?
And-
- I'm sorry, that wasn't a joke?
Interacting with the ocean?
- So of course, you know,
I've got big, big dreams
of having, and I'm sure
that this is the way
that you think about it,
when you go down to the beach
for a week, you're like, "I'm gonna surf.
I'm gonna tear it up.
I'm gonna own this.
I'm gonna, I'm gonna finally
ascend to like looking like
I know what I'm doing status."
- You're talking turning a corner.
- Right?
- Yeah.
- Never happens, of course.
- Mm.
- So we go out there the first time-
- My board never got off the top of my car
so no matter what you
say I'm gonna be jealous.
I did ride my bike a few times.
- How did that happen?
- Combination of weather
and then logistics and...
I can't, I can't get anybody
to go with me in my family.
- Surprisingly, the
boys are really into it.
And I say that just because it's not easy
and it's very, when you don't have anybody
who's really instructing you.
Right?
So we go out there and it's
a pretty big week waves wise.
And it was one of those
times where I was like,
"Good, Lord."
It was really hard to get
out past the breakers."
And the waves broke in different places.
It wasn't like a predictable,
like this is where
they're breaking every time.
It was like sometimes it'd
be like another 50 yards out
it's breaking and so you're
like, "Oh crap, I'm too far in."
So me and Locke go out there
and we're like getting beat up
and then I look back and like Shepherd,
who doesn't get out past the
breakers, he like just tries
to surf the whitewater.
- [Link] Mm-hmm.
- He is really struggling
and I'm just, I worry
that his spirit's gonna get broken.
You know?
I want him to have a
good taste in his mouth.
And then I kind of see that he's just
sort of sitting outside of the water
and sitting on the beach.
So I'm like, I go back in,
I haven't caught any waves,
I've like totally wiped
out a couple of times
just 'cause the waves were
unpredictable and it just...
I wasn't having a good
time, Locke wasn't having
a good time, Shepherded had quit.
So I like go and I'm like
trying to help Shepherd
by like taking him out there
and pushing him into the waves.
But the undertow or the
sidetow was so intense
that I could barely stay with him.
And I was like, "Man, did we pick a bad?"
Oh, the beach was rocky.
- Yeah.
- And I'm like barefoot,
I didn't bring my booties
and I was like in the water
like stepping on rocks
and like my feet hurt
and of course you're cold
because, you know, it's California.
- This is not looking good, Rhett.
- And so this is day one and I'm like,
"Oh man, is this, I knew
this was gonna happen.
I knew that the surfing
wasn't gonna be good."
I started saying things like that.
Like, "You've always got
your expectations set so high
for how things are gonna go
and how things are gonna be.
You're not, you know, I
brought my regular surfboard
and you're finally gonna be
able to do regular surfing
and not just stand up paddle boarding.
And the boys are gonna get good at it."
You know.
None of that was happening.
And so we kind of go inside
a little bit defeated
and then the next day rolls
around and there was a part
of me that was just like, "You know what,
maybe you shouldn't force it.
You shouldn't force it on yourself.
Don't force it on your kids.
Just, just, just vacate."
Is that how you do vacation?
You vacate?
- Yeah, definitely.
- "Just continue vacating and
don't worry about surfing.
If it happens, it happens."
So I'm kind of sitting
up there in the condo,
I can see the ocean and I can see some,
it's like mid-morning the next day
and I see some, and like
I didn't get up and go,
I see some guys on paddle boards
which I hadn't seen before
and they're kind of like
getting some waves and stuff.
- Mm-hmm.
- And they, I can tell that they're old.
- Nice.
- Right.
And I'm kind of in that age group.
But these guys are like 60s, gray hairs.
I mean, not that that makes you 60s.
But these guys were old.
And, I mean even white hairs.
And they are kind of killing it out there.
So I'm like, "Screw it, I'm going."
But I'm not gonna, I'm not
gonna ask the kids to go
unless they wanna go.
So I go down the steps, paddle out there,
paddle, I'm like paddling
around these old guys,
I'm like, it is a little bit calmer today,
like it wasn't so hard
to get out, that's nice.
And I'm like talking to one of the guys,
"Catching anything?"
He's like, "Oh, yeah.
Every couple of minutes
something comes along."
Oh, I wasn't like, "Yeah,
I've been watching you
from my porch."
And then I start noticing
that the dolphins are out.
- The dolphins.
- And they're not just out,
they're like putting on a show.
- What?
What do you mean?
- Well-
- Hoops? Fire?
- Two and three dolphins
at a time like are,
they're swimming in these little pods
and he, one of the old guys was like,
"Yeah the dolphins are
really feeding today."
They're like, you know,
'cause they're like literally
like swimming a couple
of feet away from you
and they're like going under
your board and then coming up
on the other side and stuff.
They know that you're there.
- It's amazing.
- Right?
- Oh, yeah.
- And they know that you're
another intelligent being
and they know that you're
into watching cool things.
And so-
- You think they're doing it for you?
- No, I think they're doing it
because they're just expressing themselves
but they also know that it's cool.
I mean their brains are bigger than ours.
- Yeah.
- They'd be, if they had
thumbs they'd be in charge.
- Well if they had thumbs
then they'd have hands
and that would look weird.
- They wouldn't be nearly
as agile if they had thumbs,
I do realize that.
- I don't think they'd be cool.
And they would know it.
- Then one of them jumps
completely out of the water.
- No, I've never seen this.
- I've never seen this
other than at SeaWorld,
which we don't go to anymore
because they don't treat them-
- Completely out of the water?
- Total dolphin body two
feet out of the water.
Head to tail complete out of the water.
- Whoa.
What?
- 20 feet away.
- Wow.
- And I'm like, "Oh yeah."
And then-
- Did you have a tear?
- No, I was just like, I'm...
I said out loud to myself,
"Always choose the experience."
- Yeah.
- That's, you know,
I was just reminding myself
I was like, "This is it, man.
I know it's hard, you're
not a great surfer,
you're frustrated, you're
kind of out of shape
and you're tall and I know
you don't have great balance
but look, you're out here
and look what's happening.
The dolphins are putting on a free show."
Then-
- Yeah.
- There's a, a one dolphin that
was a little more weathered
than the other ones.
He looked older and darker and more worn.
- Okay.
- I notice that every time
he comes up, he's snorting.
Like (snorting).
Like there was blow hole.
His blow hole's making a lot of noise.
- What?
- And I don't know if he
was doing it to be cool
or if it's just a condition
but I appreciated it.
It was like, "Wow.
I mean this guy's making all this noise."
You know, none of, the
rest of them are jumping
and doing things but this guy
he's making a lot of noise.
- Dad grunting.
- Yeah, and I appreciated that.
And then-
- That's wild.
- And then, a wave comes and I'm like...
Now I had tried to catch a
couple of waves and again-
- You were putting on a
show for the dolphins.
- Again, it's complicated.
Do you know how when you're
out, I'm out pretty far,
I'm out several hundred yards, you know?
I'm way out in the ocean.
- Uh-huh.
- Because the way that the waves work
at this particular beach,
it's a beach break,
is there's, waves of a
certain size break out there
and then they, so they
break and there's whitewater
and then they kind of stop
and then they reform early,
you know, further inside.
- Mm-hmm.
- But you want to be out there,
especially on a paddleboard,
because you don't wanna
have to get through
those every time.
So you're actually kind
of surfing these waves
on a first break way out there
and then kind of like as they
kind of dissipate you go back
out and you...
So you surf and you never
fall off your board,
you never have to peel out of the wave,
the wave just kind of dissipates.
But you get a good like
10, 12 second surf,
which is awesome.
And then sometimes if
the wave is big enough
it will reconstitute
while you're still in it
and you'll catch the second break
and take it all the way to the shore.
Right?
That did happen one time during the week.
But anyway, I catch a
wave and like I don't look
like an idiot and I do it
right and I'm in the pocket
and I'm like going sideways
and I'm like, "Yeah, dolphins,
I'm catching the waves."
And then as I'm paddling
back out there's another wave
that's coming at me and
I look into the wave
and there's two dolphins
surfing in the wave.
- What?
- Like in, their like
noses are just piercing out
of the face of the wave and they're like,
and they go right under my board.
- Really?
- Yeah.
I mean and that's not as cool
as the time I was surfing
and there were dolphins
on the wave with me
but I was just like,
"This is why I'm here."
And then, so that, the
highlight of my trip,
which, you know, the highlight of my life
is when I caught a wave and
the dolphins were on it.
The highlight of my
trip was just out there,
having chosen the experience,
having a little bit
of luck with surfing but
experiencing these dolphins.
- Dang, man, I'm envious.
- And then at that point I come back
and I tell my dolphin stories
and that kind of gets the boys
kind of back into it.
The rest of the week we went
out once, often twice a day,
Locke's catching waves,
Shepherd's catching the waves
on the inside.
And then the final day I actually met,
so my therapist lives
close by to this area,
so I actually had my therapy
appointment on the beach.
It was the most Southern
California thing ever
walking with your therapist down the beach
but I love everything about it.
And then it was like, "Can't
we have a, can't we make a,
why can't we surf during
a therapy session?
I mean, who says we can't do that?"
So we did.
- Okay.
- And Locke came out, and this was a sun,
it was literally watching
the sunset while surfing
like saw the sun go over
the horizon while surfing
and then big wave came, me
and Locke catch it together
and I'm like, "Party wave."
You always gotta say
party wave when two people
catch a wave.
And like, we're like, boards
are like two feet apart
and we're like big wave,
flying on this wave,
and I'm like, he, you know,
we're both regular footers
so he's in front of me so he can't see me,
I'm like yelling at him just
to make sure he understands
that we're on this wave
together and he's like looking
back at me and then like
he totally wipes out
right in front of me.
But after we had surfed
for a good 10 seconds.
I mean it was like we
got, we caught this wave,
it was great.
And then that was it.
That was the last.
I was so tired after that I didn't surf
the morning of the last
day it was just like,
"Boy, I'm out of shape."
But I had some special moments.
- That's amazing, man.
- Special moments.
- I'm so mad that it was you and not me.
- Yeah.
I mean, and also it just
reminded me is like we gotta,
I mean we gotta get back out there.
We gotta get back out there
on a more regular basis.
It's just, you know, we're so far...
We're so far, I mean an hour.
People don't realize
how big Los Angeles is.
We're like an hour from the beach.
- [Link] Yeah.
- So you kind of have
to make plans for it.
- But I do, I love the principle
of like as often as possible
say yes to the experience.
I love that.
Now it's your, it's your week for the rec.
- Oh.
- So...
- Say yes to the experience.
- I want to get your, get your rec,
but, you know, one of the
things you talked about
I think, I can, since
we kind of planned out
what we're gonna talk about
for the next "Ear Biscuit"
we can give a teaser.
You know, we were talking
about Lily at the top
and talking about the mentality
of coming out of COVID
and like the things you
find yourself thinking
depending on your personality
type I think has led
to some interesting
instincts that go against
what I thought I would
be feeling at this point.
What I'm talking about
is joining a commune.
As, we've started to
talk about this, right?
So then we've saved it for
next week we'll talk about
are we gonna move from
quarantine to commune life?
Because there are some
legitimate opportunities
that we could do this.
- I'm into it.
- So we'll talk about that next week.
But give us the rec.
- Okay, my rec is television related,
but it's quality television.
I'm not gonna, I'm not gonna
recommend "60 Days In."
I'm gonna recommend, this is
typical dad, this is what I do,
I recommend shows that
have been out for a while
but you may have not watched them.
"Rami" on Hulu, which so many
people had told me to watch
and I just, you know, there's
a lot of stuff to watch.
But I started watching it
just before spring break.
So it's a, you know, half
hour comedy featuring
an Egyptian American guy who,
a Muslim Egyptian American guy
who's kind of trying to
balance his life as someone
who has like a religious commitment
but is also fully American.
And it's hilarious.
It's got a lot of heart
and first of all, you know,
I don't have that, you know, I don't have
the Egyptian American
Muslim experience personally
but I understand what it's like to grow up
in a very religiously intense
environment and culture.
And also to kind of come to a place
that sees that differently,
you know, like in moving
from the East coast to the West coast,
from North Carolina to California.
Anyway, highly recommend it.
One of my favorite shows.
I mean, definitely right now.
And they're still making it I think
and it's recently won several awards
and I think the third season
is coming out at some point.
But anyway, "Rami" on
Hulu, I recommend it.
- Hashtag EarBiscuits.
Let us know what you
think, how you responded
in processing these conversations.
We enjoy reading those.
And we'll talk at you next week.
To watch more "Ear Biscuits"
click on the playlist
on the right.
- [Rhett] To watch the previous
episode of "Ear Biscuits"
click on the playlist to the left.
- [Link] And don't forget to click
on the circular icon to subscribe.
- [Rhett] If you prefer
to listen to this podcast
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your mythical best.
(upbeat music)